[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24 la
cumple del clima con 26 se fue un
encuentro crucial contra la devastación
climática pero que no logró saldar las
deudas de la humanidad para conservar el
planeta y las condiciones de vida
actuales hacia el futuro uno de los
temas que profundizan es el adeudo de la
falta de participación de las mujeres
que podemos ser potentes gestoras de
cambio pero por el contrario desde las
comunidades y aún en una situación de
desigualdad de mujeres y niñas son
víctimas del cambio climático de una
forma desproporcionada
enfrentando más riesgos particularmente
en situaciones de pobreza
por otro lado el equilibrio de género
promedio en las delegaciones de las
cumbres climáticas ha mejorado con los
años aunque sigue siendo desigual en la
cob 1 las delegaciones fueron en
promedio
88% hombres y 12% mujeres frente a los
últimos tres encuentros que han contado
con cerca de 62 por ciento de hombres
frente a 38 por ciento de mujeres
lideresas la lucha feminista también es
climática y sólo con más mujeres al
mando puede ser eficazmente gestionada y
visibilizada veamos el panorama general
la igualdad de género va de la mano con
la justicia climática la participación
de las mujeres fue parte de la agenda
central en la cumbre cop 26 en glasgow
cada año hay más mujeres en las
delegaciones climáticas pero aún es muy
desigual y los niveles más altos de toma
de decisiones todavía son controlados
por los hombres
al comienzo de la primera semana cuando
teníamos el segmento de alto nivel con
todos los jefes de estado teníamos muy
pocas jefas de estado por lo que cuanto
más alto asiente menos mujeres están en
la toma de decisiones además reportes
oficiales de la cope mostraron que los
hombres participantes en los debates
tendían a acaparar todo el tiempo de uso
de la palabra durante las mesas redondas
de discusión dejando a las liderezas en
segundo plano en muchos casos aún así en
el cuadro general la participación está
mejorando las voces femeninas necesitan
más espacio en las mesas de negociación
porque hablan de la realidad del 51% de
la población que más padece las
complicaciones del cambio climático
especialmente en el sur global se ven
afectados los sectores que dependen más
de los recursos naturales para su
sustento y que tienen menor capacidad
para responder a eventos como sequías
inundaciones y huracanes comúnmente las
mujeres son representativas de estas
situaciones por ser las más involucradas
en la producción de alimentos y las más
golpeadas por la pobreza así que son las
que primero pierden acceso a los
derechos humanos y a una calidad de vida
digna con los efectos medioambientales
nosotras somos más víctimas de los
impactos de las catástrofes climáticas
porque a menudo son las mujeres las que
regresan al bosque a plantar a buscar
algo para comer a menudo son las mujeres
las que van al bosque a cosechar y hoy
si estas mujeres no están participando
en actividades relacionadas con la lucha
contra el cambio climático podría
decirse que es nulo y sin valor porque
sus aportes la experiencia que pueden
aportar en el manejo de los recursos
naturales es muy importante en otras
ramificaciones de la crisis climática la
activista de friday es por future de
filipinas nits y tan recordó como las
mujeres se vieron obligadas a dedicarse
al trabajo sexual debido a la
devastación económica tras el tifón
hayan en el centro de filipinas en 2013
para las conversaciones sobre este tema
está en ella soy florencia ortuzar a
participante de la cob 26 y también
representante de la asociación
interamericana para la defensa del
ambiente florencia gracias por
atendernos aún desde escocia y
comenzamos el trabajo desde comunidades
es más visible y la lucha climática
también más efectiva cuando hay
tomadores de decisiones en las
representaciones de los gobiernos y de
las organizaciones
porque como beneficia a la lucha
climática la paridad de género
muchas gracias un honor estar aquí con
ustedes bueno yo diría que el asunto va
como por dos lados por un lado es
importante la participación de las
mujeres es urgente porque tenemos que
solucionar esta brecha que al final es
una injusticia y un tema de derechos
humanos no está bien simplemente no está
bien que las mujeres sean más afectadas
por el derecho por el cambio climático
sean afectadas desproporcionadamente y
sin embargo no estén ahí para tomar
decisiones no se estén tomando las
acciones para empezar a achicar esta
brecha pero por otro lado y ahí más en
relación con lo que tú preguntas las
mujeres tienen un conocimiento local y
una relación con la naturaleza que es
absolutamente clave a la hora de diseñar
las soluciones para enfrentar el cambio
climático entonces si excluimos a las
mujeres desde los espacios de toma de
decisiones no solamente estamos
cometiendo una injusticia sino que
estamos quedándonos sin todo ese valor
que realmente necesitamos más que nunca
y sin embargo los reportes que fueron
entregados por la propia kobe dan cuenta
de que los hombres acapararon el tiempo
de palabra dentro de los debates lo
sabrá usted mejor el que estuvo allá
presencialmente las mujeres de las
delegaciones perdieron así por ejemplo
oportunidades de hablar así que quisiera
preguntarle además de las cuotas
femeninas de que nos falta en un nivel
mucho más profundo para que realmente
exista paridad en la lucha climática
es que como bien dices tú tienen que
haber cambios a niveles muchísimo más
profundos que van mucho más allá de
estar midiendo el tiempo
que hablan los hombres y las mujeres
esta desigualdad tiene que ver con una
cosa histórica que ha ocurrido ya por
demasiado tiempo por ejemplo si pensamos
que las mujeres históricamente y en las
sociedades son quienes están como
ocupadas de todas las labores de cuidado
son quienes se preocupan de los niños y
las niñas más pequeños de los ancianos
de las personas con discapacidades son
las que se preocupan
generalmente de llevar el agua a las
casas la comida de calentar todo eso es
como oficios más como domésticos de
cuidado siempre han correspondido a las
mujeres entonces por ejemplo para las
mujeres es mucho más complicado así como
en la práctica ser parte de una
delegación y viajar porque alguien tiene
que hacerse cargo de cuidar a los niños
de cómo suplir todas esas labores
entonces ya como desde ese nivel y para
abajo hay como desigualdades que
complejizan que las mujeres puedan
llenar estos espacios para los hombres
es mucho más fácil porque siempre ha
sido así
estado ellos en estos como espacios de
poder en esa misma medida quisiera
hablar de como cuando oímos las
necesidades de supervivencia y de
derechos humanos de las mujeres
podríamos decir que estamos también
integrando un esfuerzo contra el cambio
climático que es para todos es que mire
en ellas hoy siempre insistimos mucho en
que proteger a la mujer como usted lo
decía es también proteger a toda la red
de cuidado que pasa por los hijos por
los adultos mayores y por sus redes
comunitarias cuando hablamos
especialmente de lideresas entonces en
qué medida proteger a las mujeres pues
va a llevarnos mucho más adelante en
esta lucha
o sea nosotros para esta lucha primero
que nada necesitamos cómo incluir a
todas las personas del mundo las mujeres
son de partida de la mejor la mitad de
la población más o menos entonces si
están subrepresentadas ya estás dejando
fuera a una cantidad importante de la
población pero más aún las mujeres
también son como bien dices tú son como
las encargadas como de
cuidar a la familia entonces tú cuando
pones a una mujer como lideresa estás
también como empujando a la familia
completa en la mujer tiene como esta
labor de aunar en las comunidades
entonces tú si tú inviertes en mujeres y
niñas estás invirtiendo también en
comunidades y eventualmente hasta en
países o sea y hay como un montón de
como detalles más por ejemplo si tú
piensas en las mujeres indígenas las
mujeres indígenas tienen una conexión
muy muy fuerte con la tierra entonces no
podemos como dejar de tener ese
conocimiento pero a la vez también hay
que tener en cuenta que no se trata
simplemente de cómo ponerlas ahí y ahora
tú se líder y soluciona el problema sino
que es un trabajo mucho más importante o
sea lo que necesitamos hoy día para
resolver este problema
para poder realmente obtener ese
conocimiento local y esa forma de hacer
las cosas que tanto necesitamos hoy día
en este mundo que está tan desbalanceado
en el tema de género es empoderar las
capacitarlas ayudarlas a sanar o sea
muchas veces las relaciones están rotas
los efectos del cambio climático han
sido tan desproporcionado que se ha
causado mucho daño entonces hace falta
que empecemos como a sanar esas heridas
para que las mujeres puedan ocupar su
lugar y ayudarnos a resolver este
problema y sin duda que vamos a poder
hacerlo de mucha mejor manera así es que
ponemos a las mujeres en el lugar donde
tienen que estar ahí tomando las
decisiones también bueno florencia y
suceden muchos activismos comunitarios
por ejemplo en américa latina' que las
lideresas actúan en protecciones de su
gente y de sus territorios pero esas
voces están desprotegidas américa latina
es el mejor ejemplo para hablar de las
peores violaciones a los derechos
humanos de activistas climáticos
incluyendo numerosas liderezas sirvió la
copa para hablar de este tema
bueno el tema de género en la cope en
esta 26 no había como nada muy complejo
que decidir se podría decir que estamos
como en un punto donde lo que se está
decidiendo es más bien como
procedimental entonces si se llegó como
a un borrador de decisión que
probablemente se va a aprobar ahora
todavía no se han tomado las últimas
decisiones pero si las personas que
estaban negociando en favor del género
como que lograron el objetivo pero
lamentablemente no es como que el
objetivo era algo muy como que no es
simplemente era como por ejemplo que los
países reconocen que la igualdad de
género un punto importante y llaman a
los países a que pongan un punto focal
de género para que estos temas empiecen
a hacer cada vez más y que estén más ahí
en la palestra y que se integren las
cuestiones de género y se llama a que el
próximo año en junio se revise el
progreso de la implementación del plan
de género que se aprobó en la copa
anterior entonces por un lado si se
podría decir que se lograron como los
objetivos de género que se habían
planteado a nivel de negociación pero
todavía no todavía como que en la
práctica visto tantos cambios igual y de
todas formas yo considero que el tema de
género si está saliendo cada vez más
como dices tú aún falta mucho pero al
menos ya es un tema que todos conocemos
y por el que se está peleando un montón
y si bien aún los hombres dominan los
espacios de poder las mujeres están
avanzando cada vez más rápido y ya por
ejemplo entre los observadores
yo diría que ya incluso hay más mujeres
que hombres ahora todavía falta llegar
más a los espacios de poder que
obviamente es lo más en lo más clave y
florencia me quedan solamente unos
segundos que quisiera preguntarle para
el cierre porque es especialmente
importante esta lucha en américa latina'
américa latina es una tierra de inmenso
valor de biodiversidad y de naturaleza y
donde también hay muchísimas comunidades
indígenas donde las mujeres juegan un
rol muy importante muy importante
entonces no solo por resolver el tema
del cambio climático y del desastre del
desastre ambiental que tenemos es un
lugar importante iniciar aquí en
latinoamérica por nosotros sino también
por el ejemplo que podemos dar para
otras regiones y también por la
necesidad de que nos unamos todas las
comunidades sobre todo las comunidades
los países más vulnerables para poder
empujar a lo que necesitamos que incluye
obviamente una mayor participación de
las mujeres como líderes y que puedan
entregar todo este conocimiento local
que es clave y es muy necesario para
enfrentar el cambio climático y que así
sea muchas gracias a usted era de
florencia ortuzar el representante
climática en un programa con la asesoría
y el apoyo de nuestra periodista
medioambiental la marina colorado sigan
en france 24 nos vemos próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]